>>> ROOT YOURSELVES BESIDE ME.
I AM THAT TREE PLANTED BY THE
RIVER WHICH WILL NOT BE MOVED.
>> WITH HER READING OF "ON THE
PULSE OF MORNING," WHEN BILL
CLINTON WAS FIRST SWORN IN AS
PRESIDENT IN 1993, MAYA ANGELOU
BECAME JUST THE SECOND POET IN
HISTORY TO RECITE A POEM AT AN
INAUGURATION.
NOW SHE'S MAKING HISTORY AGAIN
AS ONE OF 20 DISTINGUISHED WOMEN
WHO ARE ABOUT TO BE HONORED BY
THE U.S. MINT, APPEARING ON A
SERIES OF QUARTERS STARTING NEXT
YEAR.
>> AND LIFTOFF, LIFTUP OF STS
SEVEN AND AMERICA'S FIRST WOMAN
ASTRONAUT --
>> ALSO HONORED, TRAILBLAZING
ASTRONAUT SALLY RIDE WHO BECAME
THE FIRST AMERICAN WOMAN IN
SPACE ON THE SHUTTLE
"CHALLENGER" IN 1983.
THE WOMEN WILL BE FEATURED ON
THE REVERSE OR TAIL SIDE OF THE
COIN STARTING NEXT EN.
MICHELLE THOMPSON IS THE PROJECT
MANAGER.
>> IT'S A HUGE DEAL.
THE AMERICAN WOMEN QUARTERS
PROGRAM GIVES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE WOMEN OUT THERE ON
CIRCULATING COINS.
THEIR LEGACIES, THEIR
ACHIEVEMENTS, THEY'RE ALL GOING
TO BE CAPTURED ON POCKET CHANGE
FOR GENERATIONS.
>> THE U.S. MINT WILL OVERSEE
THE DESIGN WORK.
TREASURY SECRETARY JANET YELLEN
WILL APPROVE THE NOMINEES AND
FINAL DESIGN.
AND WHILE THE FRONT OR HEAD SIDE
WILL CONTINUE TO FEATURE A
LIKENESS OF GEORGE WASHINGTON,
HE'LL BE GETTING A MAKEOVER TO
DISTINGUISH THE NEW COINS WITH
SEVERAL OPTIONS BEING
CONSIDERED.
THE OTHER 18 HONOREE WHO'S HAVE
YET TO BE ANNOUNCED WILL COME
FROM A WIDE VARIETY OF FIELDS.
>> WE'RE LOOKING FOR A BROAD,
DIVERSE GROUP OF WOMEN.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE IN AMERICA,
AND THEY'RE THE TYPE OF WOMEN
WHO HAVE SHAPED WHERE WE ARE AS
A NATION.
>> ABOUT TIME.
>> HELLO.
I'M WAITING ON HARRIET TUBMAN.
>> YES.
>> ON THE -- WAS IT THE 20 OR
THE 10 -- I THINK THE 20 WOULD
BE MORE APPROPRIATE.
>> I CAN'T REMEMBER.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS THE